guys we have five players right now but  you know what would be perfect eighth  place but yeah a bad time for us yeah I  know it's the freeze-frame we're gonna  be great teammate deep in the North  Country  beyond the snowy Tundra there's a kid  named hero who's game called advice I  don't know what's wrong with I can't  miss a shot so you have to play with us  where are we the North Pole Arata okay  way down under through the bush and past  the dingo lives a man receipt pass ball  normally his name's Ben yet I mean  creating first bra time to trust the  process  my mom's gonna get mad at me if I don't  make it all together finally we head to  the far reaches of Piscataway New Jersey  to find karl-anthony a kid wise beyond  him you put some respect on my name what  happened to that boy  wait a minute my daddy Dave Oh No Eggar  [ __ ] matzo baby zero